a proposito di luci
l'estate scorsa ero in collina e mi è
capitata una cosa che non mi capitava da
trent'anni ho visto un paio di lucciole
vede ricordate le lucciole quegli
insetti quei punti di luce che si
materializzavano ma anche in città dove
abitavo io sì si vedevano la sera e la
notte e che chiaramente scatenavano la
la meraviglia l'eccitazione di noi
bambini no
l'unica cosa che quando li catturavamo
per imprigionare nella magia si
rivelavano per quello che era non c'è
dei minuscoli insetti in realtà ben poco
poetici di per loro però vederli
trent'anni dopo dopo che erano stati
spazzati via spazzate via
così come le farfalle dal
dall'inquinamento confesso che mi ha
provocato un tuffo al cuore è stato un
pochino come tornare all'infanzia no
sì me lo ricordavo bene le lucciole mi
ricordavo
sì mi ricordo anche i ghiaccioli quando
costavano 50 lire era un pezzo più buoni
di quelli che fanno oggi direi mi
ricordo mi ricordo che si faceva merenda
poi si accendeva la televisione si
guardava heidi la mia generazione
cresciuta con ai di goldrake jeeg robot
d'acciaio più bello capitan harlock
e così via mi ricordo l'arrivo della
televisione a colori la meraviglia di
quella di quella di colo getto il
telecomando si poteva comandare a
distanza
mi ricordo i mondiali dall 82 bellissimi
c'è una vittoria sordina non come quella
del 2006 che sua banale poi diciamolo
pure un pochino aiutata dalla fortuna mi
ricordo mi ricordo dopo la concomitanza
con tanto di ricordo gli stranieri che
hanno iniziato a popolare il nostro
campionato di calcio mi ricordo i
brasiliani ovviamente le cose zico
all'udinese forse qualcuno di voi se lo
ricorda
vi ricordo socrates grandissimo
giocatore ecco i brasiliani
i brasiliani in italia sono di fatto per
me la prima al primo figurazione
concreta della parola nostalgia
sì perché forse qualcuno di queste lo
ricorda i brasiliani soffrivano di souda
ci sono da c è la nostalgia in
portoghese d'accordo ed era in qualche
modo legata al fatto che rimpiangevano
la madrepatria socrates non giocò in
modo splendido in italia complice la
saudage di fatto questa cosa c'è il
rimpianto della casa come fondamento
della nostalgia
non è strano perché a fine seicento
quando si codifica in chiave medica la
nostalgia si suppone che sia è a partire
da alcuni casi che si presentano i
soldati svizzeri distanza nelle
guarnigioni straniere che sviluppano dei
sintomi di malessere di sofferenza
arrivano in alcuni casi addirittura a
morire perché manca loro l'esperienza
del domestica villaggio natio e così via
ora questo tipo di sofferenza è
evidentemente reversibile e curabile
basta tornare a casa in alcuni casi però
il ritorno a casa non è sufficiente
perché se è intercorso un lasso
temporale sufficiente la casa il
villaggio e così via che si ritrova è
diverso è cambiato allora la nostalgia
diventa quello che noi più forse
conosciamo sia l'esperienza di una
perdita il dolore di una perdita di un
tempo che non può più essere recuperato
ora è in questa forma direi che la
nostalgia sembra essere diventata la
cifra del nostro tempo
sicuramente la nostalgia presiede a
tutta una serie di linguaggi e di forme
culturali pensate ad esempio quanto la
pubblicità ricorre in modo più o meno
sistematico o frequente se non altro
alle tecniche nostalgiche per promuovere
i propri oggetti pensate non so le
automobili alcuni dei modelli di maggior
successo degli ultimi vent'anni sono
rivisitazioni di modelli del boom
economico a 500 il maggiolone e così via
d'accordo pensate in primis ovviamente
alla moda
voglio dire le scarpe più vendute sono
delle scarpe che erano in uso negli anni
70 d'accordo non indossano i ragazzini e
li indossano anche chi ragazzi non è più
è però cerca magari pateticamente di
fare il giovane sicuramente sicuramente
la nostalgia è centrale tempio nella
musica esistono volumi importanti come
questo ad esempio che è dedicato alla
scena musicale degli ultimi 15 anni si
retromania sostanzialmente ipotesi
abbastanza plausibile che da trent'anni
a questa parte dalla metà degli anni
ottanta in modo specifico si sia entrato
in un processo in cui la cifra di
elaborazione musicale è il remake
d'accordo la cover la variazione si
recuperano gli stilemi del passato e
così via
in realtà la nostra è un'epoca in
qualche modo ossessionata dalla
nostalgia come cifra di una retromania
d'accordo in qualche modo si moltiplica
gli anni zero paradossale di spregio
alle leggi della matematica hanno
moltiplicato ma non hanno evidentemente
creato
non è un caso che le due tecnologie che
hanno forse dato più forza e più forma
alla nuova socialità la nuova socialità
non è quella della panchina una dalla
conversazione in panchina giusto solo i
social network entrambe le tecnologie
che hanno dominato la scena penso a
facebook ea instagram sono dominate da
una logica nostalgica facebook è
l'annuario scolastico nasce come
tentativo come strumento per recuperare
persone della nostra adolescenza persona
che abbiamo perso di vista
d'accordo magari per sorridere
ripensando a un bacio dato oppure
strapparsi i capelli se ci sono ancora
rimpiangendo un bacio non dato da corde
questo è stato in qualche modo il motore
instagram mi sembra fine evidente
instagram è definito dalla dal filtro
che elabora le immagini sono filtri che
producono un effetto seppiato polaroid
possiamo dirlo semplificando d'accordo
esercito non straordinario fascino non
solo su chi come me ha usato la polaroid
e starà ricorda come oggetto d'uso
anche sui ragazzi su chi ha vent'anni
oggi che la polaroid non sa minimamente
cosa è stata allora evidentemente la
nostalgia non è più legata ad una
specifica formazione i soldati svizzeri
i brasiliani e così via è diventata in
qualche modo esperienza di confronto con
la realtà che ci circonda
in effetti si può sostenere che se
l'ottocento è stato il secolo dominato
dal passato pensate all'evoluzionismo la
geologia a quella forma di ricerca
storica e così via
e il novecento è stato il secolo
dominato dal futuro se novecento si apre
con il in italia col futurismo non è
tanto questo si apre con le grandi
prospettive anche se volete sicuramente
si apre con l'esplosione della
fantascienza da un punto vista politico
si apre con l'utopia della democrazia
realizzata e dall'altro con i
totalitarismi che bene o male comunque
erano presieduti da un radioso avvenire
da una dimensione di futuro ok il
novecento è sicuramente il secolo del
futuro il 21esimo secolo sembra essere
il secolo dominato dal dal presente da
una forma quasi paradossale spaventosa
di prigionia del presente stesso
l'ipotesi è che in qualche modo alla
fine del novecento il tempo sia andato
in arresto l'emblema ce lo offre un film
che forse qualcuno ricorda ritorno al
futuro del 1985
c'è una une un orologio che è bloccato
come in italia il 2 agosto 1980
l'esplosione di bologna fissa congela il
tempo con l'orologio che in qualche modo
risulta iconico ancora oggi
ora cosa racconta ritorno al futuro
ritorno al futuro è presuppone presenta
una macchina del tempo un'automobile
letteralmente del tempo che non conduce
però al futuro come dovrebbe fare bensì
per un errore scaraventa il protagonista
nel passato nel 55 come a dire il futuro
cessa di avere la dimensione di
prospettiva verso il futuro e diventa
quasi una forma nevrotica di sguardo
verso il passato appunto
l'orazione remake la ricombinazione
senza una dimensione di creazione ex
nihilo creazione nuova ora cosa avviene
peraltro in ritorno al futuro il
protagonista confrontandosi con il 55 si
trova a incontrare i suoi genitori nel
momento stesso in cui si stanno
avvicinando rho e fa in modo che si
avvicinino perché se no lui non
nascerebbe e tuttavia fa in modo anche
di infondere nei due genitori una
fiducia che evidentemente nella sua
linea del tempo nelle 85 quando viveva
lui non avevano d'accordo la madre
alcolizzata il padre un fallito o in
qualche modo cosa fa marty ossia il
protagonista è la bora o meglio
interviene modificando il corso del
tempo
quindi quando si ritroverà nel 85 quando
tornerà nel suo presente
esisterà in una forma cosmetica cioè la
madre sarà una donna piacevole in gamba
il padre sarà un uomo di successo con la
macchina sportiva che regala il giappone
al figlio eccetera
ossia avrà trasformato la sua realtà al
disegna di un tempo cosmetico la cosa
falsificato in questo senso si può
sostenere che la realtà in cui noi ci
troviamo e dominato da questo principio
di cosmesi e una forma di stasi del
tempo non è di fatto incompatibile con
quello che ciascuno di noi può osservare
ossia siamo in realtà ossessionati dalla
dimensione della novità siamo assaltati
dalle novità ogni giorno d'accordo
tecnologiche e di altra natura il
principio dell'innovazione sembra essere
un principio che attraversa e che
governa ogni nostra singola giornata
allora come è possibile sostenere che
l'ossessione per la novità vada di pari
passo con una stasi temporale col tempo
in arresto il tempo cosmetico di quello
di cui ho parlato
beh basta prendere il secondo ritorno al
futuro il sequel marty finisce nel 2015
cioè l'anno prossimo e si ritrova
circondato da un futuro che in realtà è
molto simile al suo presente all 85
semplicemente a una serie di gadget al
frigorifero che dice quando finisce
latte oppure a le scarpe che si
allacciano da sole d'accordo allora il
futuro che si inizia a pensare a 85 è un
futuro molto simile al presente
semplicemente ha degli elementi di
novità allora come ripeto coniugare
l'incitazione alla innovazione con la
stasi
c'è un'immagine che forse non è
lusinghiera ma che forse è efficace
avete presente il criceto il criceto
vive in una gabbia in cui un giorno è
simile all'altro quello prima è uguale a
quello dopo
d'accordo ogni giorno costantemente
uguale come passa il tempo il criceto
beh corre a una ruota e quello è il suo
modo di affrontare costantemente il
principio di novità corre inseguito e
stimolato dalle novità di corsa di corsa
contemporaneamente questa sorta di
ossessione al rinnovamento al
cambiamento si traduce in una forma di
stasi perché il criceto è sempre
immobile e sempre in realtà fermo nella
sua cornice nella sua gabbia
ecco forse la condizione del ventunesimo
secolo oppure che come di e governa la
gran parte di noi sono un altro è
assimilabile a questa dimensione di
inseguimento della novità che presuppone
la rinuncia ad ogni forma radicale di
trasformazione ad ogni forma radicale di
cambiamento
d'accordo ora come pensare in qualche
modo questa nostra realtà
forse la nostra condizione non è così
dissimile da quella dei soldati svizzeri
del seicento nella misura in cui
esistiamo in una forma di esilio
l'esilio in cui esistiamo è quello
rispetto ad una realtà
d'accordo la realtà con cui ci
confrontiamo evidentemente ci sfugge ma
non perché non abbiamo la tecnologia
eccetera perché il linguaggio attraverso
cui pensiamo la realtà non è più
adeguato
ecco che ci troviamo in qualche modo
stranieri in esilio
in assenza rispetto ad una mancanza di
presa nei confronti del reale ecco forse
dove volendo ipotizzare una cura
dobbiamo cercare di muoverci ossia
elaborare non tanto una forma di
inseguimento delle singole novità che
vanno bene ma sono diciamocelo la ruota
del criceto bisogna lavorare per
trasformare le categorie cognitive
attraverso cui costruiamo il nostro
senso la nostra appartenenza al mondo
perché di fatto è attraverso il
ripensare le coordinate del presente che
è possibile reinserirci in un asse
temporale
c'è una dimensione che collega il
passato che possono essere i libri con
il presente del tablet e con il futuro
quel futuro che completamente elementare
ma non è semplicemente da fare bisogna
elaborare degli strumenti che ci
consentano di concepirlo questa
dimensione prospettica sul futuro in
realtà forse ci è venuta meno e di nuovo
un film o meglio due film ci possono
illustrare questa sorta di nostalgia di
del presente del del futuro e questa
sorta di stallo in cui siamo a spielberg
tra a cavallo tra gli anni settanta gli
ottenere gli anni 80 lavora fa due film
di fantascienza il primo è incontri
ravvicinati del terzo tipo di nuovo
abbiamo il futuro d'accordo il futuro
dell'alieno con cui ci si confronta quel
film mette in gioco la meraviglia e lo
stupore l'incantamento per la visione
d'accordo con la visione che oggi forse
governati dominate di gas non abbiamo
abbiamo perso dopo cinque anni è lo
stesso spielberg
siamo nel 82 distribuisce c'è gira e
distribuisce un film che successivo di
fantascienza che è e chi la differenza
mi sembra radicale altrimenti quel
mostriciattolo rambaldi che ebbe anche
la oscar per gli effetti speciali
allora e di essi un alieno e sicuramente
produce una forma di meraviglia
è la forma di meraviglia però devo di
incantamento che è tipico del bambino
non più dell'adulto e soprattutto e ti
ha uno slogan che è telefono casa
telefono casa che ripete ossessivamente
allora la casa il rimpianto dalla casa
perduta
l'alieno dietil extraterrestre è un
extraterrestre un alieno nostalgico
ecco che in qualche modo in quella fase
ad un tempo con l'arresto del tempo con
l'inaugurazione del tempo cosmetico si
mette in gioco in buona sostanza una
forma di nostalgia ossessiva che è anche
una nostalgia del futuro
elano è la mancanza di prospettiva
ora qui forse presiede la dimensione di
cura che noi possiamo cercare non dico
trovare ma cercare ossia si tratta di
ritrovare una forma di come dire di
posizione nel mondo a livello ripeto
cognitivo
c'è un film recente drive xvi che aveva
la cosa più bella forse l'avete visto
la cosa più bella era lo slogan log line
ossia don't let down non mollare in quel
caso era il non mollare nel senso e
resistere ma era anche dato che la metà
fra quella del cordone ombelicale che
collega la protagonista lo shuttle e poi
alla e quindi in ultima analisi alla
terra e per non mollare cioè per
resistere bisogna mollare bisogna
lasciare andare lasciar passare il
passato d'accordo
ora questo è quello che forse dobbiamo
sforzarci di fare cioè ricollocarci in
una linea temporale accettare in qualche
modo che abbiamo una posizione che c'è
un passato che è dietro di noi e cenni
necessariamente un futuro verso il quale
dobbiamo costringerci a rivolgere lo
sguardo ora c'è solo una cosa peggiore
come insegna il film gravity c'è solo
una cosa peggiore del perdere la casa e
vivere nel rimpianto della casa perduta
c'è solo una cosa peggiore dall
invecchiare e da rimpiangere la
giovinezza che non c'è più si tratta in
qualche modo di cercare una nuova casa
accettando il fatto che possa non essere
come quella che avevamo
si tratta in qualche modo di rinunciare
forse all'orsacchiotto che ciascuno di
noi si porta in giro metaforicamente si
tratta di lasciare che siano i nostri
figli ai nostri allievi chi viene dopo
di noi in qualche modo ad averne uno
e che magari non si sa come il nostro
solo così facendo troveremo ritroveremo
la dimensione di tempo d'accordo dalla
direzione che è il senso stesso della
nostra posizione del mondo ora in questo
senso è necessario uscire dal tempo
cosmetico è necessario uscire dalla
ruota del criceto
se non altro per curiosità se non altro
per vedere uscendo come va a finire
grazie